Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on SHIELD, Cobie Smulders came back, we finally
found out who was behind Project TAHITI and
one of the best escape plans I’ve seen all
season.
I don’t know if it was because of Cobie’s
comedic background, but for a number of reasons
we can talk about the whole episode felt like
it was funnier.
If you’re finding me for the first time.
I’m doing weekly SHIELD videos and I do
bonus Marvel movies videos every Tuesday.
Today we learned about the new Episode VII
cast, so naturally if a bomb like that gets
dropped it ends up being the bonus video.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
As soon as SHIELD is over, Star Wars videos
will fill the Tuesday night Gap.
So let’s talk about how awesome Robin Sparkles
is, careful for spoilers if you haven’t
seen the episode yet.
But here are my top 5 moments.
Number 5 - Ward Is Hitler Youth
Their big fight was a nice explosion we’d
all been waiting to happen.
I wasn’t really digging the Mr and Mrs Smith
diner scene so when they finally did have
it out on the Bus I was really happy.
Usually when you put characters in these confessional
scenes is when the truth starts to come out.
And we learned a couple things:
Skye knows the SHIELD handbook, Chapter 1,
Red Skull founded HYDRA, he was a super NAZI.
Ergo all HYDRA Agents are probably Nazi’s.
One of the funniest lines in the episode.
And Skye is done with Ward, as expected, she
says she’s never going to give him what
he wants.
Meaning the information on the drive and her
cash and prizes.
But that’s a lie isn’t it?
She totally gave up the drive when she thought
Deathlok was going to kill him.
So I think that opens the door for a Ward
redemption arc.
There was also some stuff later at the motel
that supports that theory.
Number 4 - Team Coulson On Vacation
I love scenes like this when it’s just the
Team chilling together out in public.
It’s like that scene in Iron Man 2 when
Tony Stark goes to get Donuts and Nick Fury
and Black Widow share some coffee.
Maybe it’s just seeing super heroes doe
mundane everyday things like use a vending
machine and hang out by the pool?
I think this is where the real character development
happens.
Where you start to fall in love with these
people.
If you ever watched any of Joss Whedon’s
older shows like Buffy or Angel or Firefly.
The best scenes where when they were just
hanging out being friends.
I’m not sure where the team is going to
be after the finale, Maria Hill told Coulson
to release them all to Stark Industries, but
I don’t see that happening.
Especially since we know Nick Fury is still
alive.
Fitz and Simmons also said something that
makes me think the show is laying groundwork
for a Ward redemption.
Like when Fitz says he doesn’t believe that
some people are just evil.
It’s like Darth Vader in Return of the Jedi
all over again.
Maybe that means Ward will throw Garrett down
an elevator shaft too.
Let me know if you agree.
Number 3 - Cobie Smulders Is Back
I love the Maria Hill character, so naturally
when How I Met Your Mother ended I crossed
my fingers that she’d guest star on SHIELD
more often.
That’s probably not going to happen, mostly
because her movie career is starting to take
off and she outranks Coulson.
And really he should be the most powerful
main character week to week.
She also moved back to New York to live with
her husband Tarran Killam who’s on SNL full
time and SHIELD shoots in Los Angeles.
But I think we can expect her to show up at
least three or four times during season 2.
I loved the casual way she just name-dropped
Man Thing and Stark’s Army.
Your brain naturally races to his Armory as
in hall of Armors.
I’ll talk about that more in a future Avengers
video, but Joss Whedon is kind of glossing
over the end of Iron Man 3.
So he’ll have multiple Armors again.
What I’d really like to see from her if
she’s in the finale at all is a full on
fight scene.
Like with Garrett.
She’s supposed to be one of the most fearsome
SHIELD agents, so why isn’t she punching
more people like May does?
Number 2 - Lola Is The New Escape Plan
One of the best escapes all season.
I can only imagine how much the spent on that
effect but all I could think when they backed
the car out and Skye flew up in the air was
“that’s why you wear a seatbelt”.
Disney is a family company, so if feel like
they could run this scene by itself as a seat
belt safety PSA in schools.
Coulson’s reaction to Deathlok was priceless
too.
His Oh Shit face is going to be one of my
favorite gifs from the episode.
New plan, run.
and my Number 1 moment - The Man Behind TAHITI
Is Revealed
I did not see this coming.
Coulson being the man behind TAHITI.
I saw a lot of you commenting on Twitter that
this was confusing.
So here’s what was going on.
Nick Fury commissioned project TAHITI as a
way of using alien, probably Kree, DNA to
develop regenerative drugs that they could
use on mortally wounded Avengers.
So say Tony Stark or Black Widow almost dies
or does die.
They wanted a procedure that could bring them
back to life.
Like the Mirakuru on Arrow, minus the super
strength.
But just like on Arrow with the mirakuru.
The alien blood made everyone flip their shit.
The only way to fix the problem was to re-write
the people’s memories.
Because it was so shady, Coulson tendered
his resignation and advised Nick Fury to scrap
the project.
What probably happened was Fury did scrap
the project, but then when Coulson died during
Avengers, it was still sitting there in the
bunker.
So he used it that once on Coulson and based
on Coulson’s notes.
Knew that the had to re-write his memory.
So that he wouldn’t go crazy and die.
So Fury wasn’t trying to be shady, he just
wanted Coulson to be stable and alive.
But because they weren’t sure, Fury ordered
May to watch him.
Samuel L. Jackson is guest starring in the
finale.
So I’m sure there will be a scene where
the two of them resolve the issue.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what you’re favorite moment
was.
Cobie Smulders, TAHITI or Lola?
I think we should call Chloe Bennett’s Haircut
after they landed the Lola.
All it will be is you sitting in front of
a blow drier for fifteen minutes.
Perfect for Halloween.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus.
I loved seeing Maria Hill again and the way
they used her character to create a bridge
between Winter Soldier and Avengers 2.
Remember she said they’re privatizing World
Security.
That’s going to be a thing in Avengers Age
of Ultron.
We can talk more about that in a future video.
But I’m really glad the Skye and Ward drama
is over.
And now they can just start punishing each
other with Hitler Jokes.
The Coulson TAHITI twist was a nice wrinkle.
I’m actually surprised that the mystery
has gone on this long.
I wasn’t super invested in it and I think
a lot of us thought it might be another Alexander
Pierce HYDRA reveal but I like the real explanation
better.
No one can hurt you like your friends.
He and Nick Fury are going to have some serious
words.
I’m really excited to see where the end
of this season leaves the team.
I don’t expect them to disband, but they
might take funding from Tony Stark.
I have a feeling he’ll be funding the Avengers
during Age of Ultron.
Remember, privatizing world security.
In related news once SHIELD goes away, Tuesdays
will permanently be my Star Wars and Marvel
Movie video day.
There are two more episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And leave me suggestions for my next bonus
video.
Right now click here to learn about the new
Star Wars Episode 7 cast and click here for
last week’s Agents of SHIELD.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!